يا
إلهي ، يا إلهي ، يا إلهي ،
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى] ،
هذا عزيزتي بريتا ، أردت أن أكتب
لك وأشكرك شخصيًا على خدمتك
في الخطوط الأمامية
لهذا الوباء ولأنك شجاع بما يكفي لوضع
نفسك في خطر لمساعدة الآخرين ،
لقد ألهمني شغفك
بالأمل والاهتمام
بالصبر ، وقد تأثرت للغاية لدرجة أنك
ذكرت إعجابي بموسيقاي مؤخرًا ،
لقد أرسلت لك بعض الملابس المريحة المجنونة
عندما تكون خارج الخدمة.
سأفكر فيك وحب ممتن إلى الأبد
تايلور
أنا أموت ، يا إلهي ، الجزء المفضل لدي
حول الرسالة هو
في النهاية ، قالت
سأفكر فيك وستكون ممتنة إلى الأبد
أم تحب تايلور وستقول فقط
شيء من هذا القبيل
أنها ستفكر بي
وأنها ممتنة لشيء أقوم به
إنه مؤثر حقًا وقد
أحببت حقًا هذا الجزء كثيرًا ،
فهناك الملايين من الأشخاص الذين يفعلون
الشيء الذي أفعله ، لذا أعتقد أنها
تقول شكرًا  لك لهم
جميعًا أيضًا  NK لك على ذلك ،
شكرًا لك على تخصيص الوقت
للجلوس وكتابة رسالة مكتوبة بخط اليد
مما يعني أن العالم بالنسبة لي شخصي للغاية
وهذا ما سأقوله لها
وربما أبكي